it pas le plan mais qu'elle ne
manifesterait pas non plus le 25 alors
le secrétaire général de la CFDT
François cherrek joue gros dans cette
affaire il est contesté à l'intérieur
même de sa centrale il rend des visites
précisément aujourd'hui au Congrès des
retraités CFDT et l'accueil a été disons
mitigé François Privat Emmanuel
sarmion sous le choc depuis le 15 mai
leur message est clair ces militants du
Sgen Cfdt tous membres de l'éducation
nationale tournent le dos à François CHK
qui de son côté a également préféré les
éviter quelques retraités CFDT quittent
alors leur congrès pour débattre sur le
trottoir ce que CH a accepté comme
compromis au niveau des enseignants ça
vous gêne c'est ça que je veux
savoirignant c'est au niveau de la CFDT
dans son ensemble enfin il y avait des
plateformes revendicatives on a lâché
tous les autres là tout d'un coup en 2
he et lorsque François ch se présente à
la tribune du
Congrès
on n pas consulté sa base pour prendre
des décisions on avait le temps de
négocier nos militants ont besoin des
explication et c'est une des raisons
pour lesquelles je suis ici aujourd'hui
à La Rochelle demain ou après-demain je
serai ailleurs mais on va s'expliquer
François vient donc de s'engager dans
une croisade de l'explication qui
s'annonce
difficile